nous sommes ici au siège de
l'association amarré aux camélias à
saint denis depuis une vingtaine
d'années valérie imache collabore à
aider à l'accueil du jeune fille mère
depuis les premiers balbutiements du
mouvement créé par soeur marie noëlle à
l'actuelle association où travaillent
une vingtaine de personnes elle a vu
naître de nombreux bébés à peine plus
âgés que leurs mamans de son
irremplaçable expérience à l'amour
qu'elle porte à enseigner les rudiments
de la couture à ses pensionnaires de
passage elle nous emmène aujourd'hui
dans un monde pas très loin de chez nous
avant tout de la wii vous êtes dans
l'atelier danse et ce qu'il faut c'est
travailler le plus de plus et avec les
filles avec les mamans et avec les bébés
d'accord
allô bonjour au début vous faisiez que
de la ligue est maintenant elle allait
évoluer dans votre travail de couture et
des draps
services d'état mais maintenant on fait
aussi des petits trucs artisanale
dans le genre tablier dont poupée sacs à
pain et sable de plage ont fait tout ce
qui concerne le ti si exotique on essaye
de travailler dessus
mais les génère donc elles n'ont qu'une
de son couture quand elle arrive au
centre bazas passe c'est à dire la
plupart ils sont difficiles c'est pas
tout le monde et donc pour la couture
mais il pas remis il y a quelques unes
qui se monte un petit peu de vous et
dans la couture ça fait qui contraignent
les autres à faire tout le monde j'ai
réussi à faire quelque chose de mon
univers semblable à lot donc ça fait
qu'ils ont réussi comme ça à faire des
petits travaux et commencions petit et
fuir la misère ben ça ça ça vient mais
malheureusement au moment qu'ils
s'entêtent des choses et c'est le moment
il faut partir raconte l'arrivée du bébé
d'accord et vos travaux font exploser ou
pas les travaux défis sont exposés à
l'exposition fait main en deux fois par
an ou autrement en vend aussi sur place
et puis on fait aussi dans les paroisses
est en fait dans ma paroisse st on est
d'accord avec le psg pour présenter la
fête des mères ou en fin d'année ont
fait dispositions sur la paroisse à la
sortie des messes et ça se passe très
bien il ya le change entre vous et les
jets les jeunes oui il ya beaucoup il ya
beaucoup et puis ils sont attentifs ils
firent quelque chose par exemple le plus
difficile c'est de rassembler ces petits
carrés la wii est fait à ce jeune shia
labeouf vient le mal à faire ce jeune
chien ça c'est difficile ils sont un
petit peu cher' excité afin de mettre
des petits carrés des petits carrés
parfois s'attend pas bien parfois si
trop grand les caries c'est pas bien
assemblé ça posait problème mais
autrement de trucs comme ça c'est facile
à faire mais il faut le temps mais ils
sont quand même
il accepte pas travailler ni puis ils
font leurs crochets les la broderie de
calvin ça aussi ça passait bien avec
elle parce qu'elles continuent ce
qu'elles ont commencé à faire chez vous
ici c'est qu'elle continue il y en a qui
sont de la couture maintenant qui fait
des retouches dos des magasins j'ai lu
il ya deux mois de cela j'ai rencontré
une aide m'a dit tu sais madame images
de travail dans sept magasins et puis là
je partirai pas tous de l'autre côté et
ça marche très bien mais je suis
contente pour elle parce que et presque
tout il ya quand même les qui vont y
serez ici bien ce qu'ils ont appris au
centre
parce que même temps cela fait sept
enfants l'âge de 6 ans remplace de
plantes mais le mystique connaît même
pas non plus quel avenir si tu vas
donner un à ces enfants là le problème
c'est ça et les parents des parents
parfois on a beaucoup de choses qui est
zappée par rendre compte personnellement
ça ne tient pas non plus à occuper ces
jeunes on a tous ces problèmes harriet
pas mal des choses qui rend dans le g et
qui ramène à fait à la cia faire un bébé
voit pas famille penser comme ça parce
qu'il n'est pas possible
l'enfant est la personne la fille allait
à l'école elle un bon niveau elle y
travaille bien et puis tout d'un coup
craint
elle attend un bébé
mais il faut arrêter la coupure mais
qu'on va recommencer sera plus pareil
passé quand même bébé sur le banc
parce que vous vous croyez que ça manque
de dialogue entre parents et enfants des
conférences lui croit que c'est un
manque de dialogue mais c'est un manque
d'amour oui de l'école parce qu'il ya
des fois nous nouvelles des enfants
nécessiteux cela mais il faut voir ce
que l'enfant enlevé aussi au fond de lui
même il serait d'aller avancer
maintenant à ça mais nous nous vu
autrement mais ça fait que l'enfant la
donner la vie
les facile et difficile en même temps et
toutes les choses les apporter de l'udc
met à l'abri de rien le problème ce que
quand le syndicat ce le verrou tourner
en arrière mais n'est pas ça ait de
problème mais je ne désenfle pas tous
lancé c'est marie noëlle régna la
fondatrice du centre aux états unis et
en même temps la fondatrice de
l'association amarré à marie qui veut
dire à marie qui veut dire à moore en
latin elle avait choisi ça parce qu'
elle voulait mettre quelque chose comme
nous c'est cette association qui touche
le coeur et qui est quelque chose qui
fait sentir que les fait avec amour tout
a commencé dans dans une église sous le
hangar d'une église de saint joseph
ouvriers avec trois ou quatre jeunes
filles qui étaient là et qui faisaient
la couture tous les jours mais avec sur
rosiers un génie et sur marie noëlle
mais comme ce temps là ça ne pouvait pas
durer justement dans sous le hangar
d'une église est là d une petite
participation à la fuite les zones la
fuite avec les femmes qui travaillent la
couture qui font la cuisine est pas mal
les choses
aujourd'hui le bébé a grandi
subventionné par la caf le conseil
général ahmar et gir 3 foyers dont deux
pour les jeunes filles mineures elles
bénéficient ainsi d'un encadrement
professionnel en même temps qu affectif
pour franchir le difficile obstacle
d'une grossesse qui n'a pas forcément
prévenu mais qu'elle accepte d'assumer
pour donner une chance à la vie
amarré fonctionne durant 24h 24 heures
pour la fin
les filles qui sont là ils sont tous les
jours ouais et ils sont accompagnés ils
sont aidés par ramaré et ils ont un
suivi jusqu'à la sortie de la suite de
cette association quand elle arriva sont
incertains défavorisés oui oui elles
sont déjà en scène ou bien parfois elle
arrive aussi avec le bébé il y en a qui
arrivent avec un bébé dans c'est comme
ça est ce que votre but c'est aussi
d'apprendre ces jeunes vient d'être
indépendante de willy beaucoup beaucoup
passez moi mon rôle à moi c'est de les
apprendre afin de préparer la layette et
ensuite de les aider un petit peu lourd
allemand
l'accompagner et le suivre jusqu'à en
fait de temps en temps il vient de me
revoir pour pas mal de choses donc on se
rend compte dans ce sens là et nous
sommes là parce que moi mais nous sommes
là pour les aider pour les mets l'écouté
de
l'été un petit peu comme leur maman
horizons ami on m'appelle mamie parce
que ça c'est une histoire un petit peu
triste mais maintenant je suis fier de
mattel manille parce que c'est une fille
que j'ai aidé depuis pas mal de temps et
puis un jour je vais pas pleurer devant
moi et me disais mamie tu sais et je
dois rentrer dans ma maison alors j'ai
dit mais c'est bien mais ça m'a touché
vraiment et depuis ce jour pas mal je
dirais même même les personnels on
m'appelle mamies et les autres filles
qui arrivent maintenant nous sommes en
2001 et qui m'appelle toujours amis et
ça me fait beaucoup plaisir comment se
déroule la journée pour une chaîne verte
y ait deux foyers de la journée ça
commence toujours
la maman et a déjà son bébé ça commence
par le bain du bébé ensuite le petit
déjeuner ces activités c'est à dire le
ménage chacun a son petit ça fait et
puis ceux qui vont à l'atelier pour
faire la couture quelques les emmène et
dans la meilleure du possible chez ag
ramène où ils viennent chercher et
ensuite l'après midi il y à compertrix
avec une monitrice et il ya aussi un
film à regarder et en fermant document
de sur le film et puis moi la sienne le
bain des soirées puis le repas est
ensuite allé quoi il manque cette
semaine maintenant mon rôle un petit peu
plus grande parce que j'occupe aussi de
l'économat et du service d'entretien et
ont plus que j'occupe les filles et les
bébés ceux qui s'occupent de découpe pas
l'europe un briard en cuisinière qui
s'occupe de repart le matin et le soir
et qui font aussi un petit peu le ménage
chacun a sa tâche dans cette maison il
ya beaucoup de jeunes mères qui restent
dans leur foyer propre dans la famille
nous il y en a d'autres il ya des
retours qui ont besoin de venir dans un
centre comme à maré quoi ben parce
qu'ils ont besoin
de changement ils ont besoin d'eux à mon
avis assumer leurs process avec plus de
sécurité d'accord je dis pas que dans la
famille également mais
du fond du coeur et il voulait connaître
des choses autrement et vivre cette
grossesse par cachet mais
lui rassuré comment la vie mais il n'y a
pas forcément une coupure a dit non non
il n'ya pas de coupure au contraire
mais
les filles rencontrent les parents vont
week-end les parents puis dans le foyer
pour rencontrer vous même vous avez des
enfants
gpat enfants les fusils d'assaut et huit
petits enfants de 14 ans et 22 jours le
dernier vous trouver du temps pour
s'occuper d'un c'est-à-dire j'essaye de
trouver du temps à ses fins temps pour
la famille travail et c'est bien mais il
faut un temps pour la famille donc je
cherche un petit peu sur mon travail et
mes enfants et ma maison mon loyer êtes
maman nous est mamie vous côtoyer tous
les jours des des jeunes mères en
difficulté
qu'est ce que vous avez envie de dire à
ce même si au femmes au même je voudrais
dire quand même vous voir comme un
message pour le jeune qui me regarde en
ce moment et pour les femmes qui qui
cherche quelque chose de ne pas se
décourager au contraire dans la vie il
faut se battre il faut se combattre des
mouvements et les difficultés c'est tous
les jours et il faut le vivre mais
parfois il faut faire silence et être
confiant
confiante elle même les continuer à
lutter pas sûr du tout tant qu'on aura
la vie il faut éviter ça s'arrête pas